is Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and actress
that's the new conspiracy theory
floating around the internet and it's
entirely correct but not for the reasons
that many think we will investigate who
is really pulling a o'seas marionette
strings then bado beats our expectations
Kirsten Gillibrand doesn't and the kids
are not alright I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
all right first of all I want to thank
everybody for the birthday wishes yeah
yesterday was my birthday a lot of
people sent over very nice things so
thank you very much I appreciate it just
for you I refrained from indulging in
true birthday debauchery so that I would
not be speaking in cursive on today's
show and actually able to talk about
this because there is a great conspiracy
theory going around the internet that
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez is an actress
this is a particularly great conspiracy
theory because it's true although people
are drawing the wrong conclusions from
it it is true but we'll explain how it's
true first let's make a little money
honey with purple mattress you know how
much I don't even want to read I'm not
gonna read any of the bullet points that
I've written down here I'm gonna speak
just from the heart and from the back
because my back feels so much better
ever since I've slept on purple mattress
it's the best bet I've ever slept on it
is not quite a memory foam it's not an
innerspring it is something completely
new developed by a rocket scientist it's
this material that is soft and firm at
the same time how is that possible I
have no idea when they sent me this
mattress I was very skeptical I almost
didn't even try it out I tried out for
one night because I liked my old bed I
tried out for one night completely
hooked through my bed out the next day
my old bed this thing is a complete game
changer I love it I have recommended
this to family and friends you have got
to try it it has a 109 risk free trial
if you're not fully satisfied you can
return the mattress for a full refund
you will not want to return the mattress
they've free in-home set up an old
mattress removal backed by a 10 year
warranty a just a superb night's sleep
you've never felt anything like it check
it out right now my listeners get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts they're offering site-wide
just text knowles kayano wles like
Beyonce 2 8 4 8 8 8 the only way to get
this free pillow is to text knowles KO
wles like Beyonce to 8 for 8 8 8 that is
K nowl es to 8 for 8 8 8 message and
data rates may apply is Alexandria ok
Jie
portes an actress this is a theory that
cropped up from a YouTube account called
mr. Reagan and this guy goes through a
o'seas history and he makes the claim
that she's not really some motivated
movement politician she was cast in a
casting call from a group called the
Justice Democrats they plucked this girl
out of obscurity and she is now just a
mouthpiece she's a sort of Charlie
McCarthy doll or a little marionette and
the strings are being pulled by a group
called the Justice Democrats and he
presents a lot of evidence for this
theory including aoc speaking about it
herself and the group the Justice
Democrats speaking about it themselves
there's a great video it's like 20
minutes long here's just a small clip of
that to show you what he's talking about
and it flats we became friends with one
of the bartenders who we call sandy you
all know her as Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
but in the early day she was just
serving us margaritas and listening to
us talk back in 2016 we put out a call
for nominations we got over 10,000
nominations out of those 10,000
nominations we found Alexandria my
brother told me that he had sent my
nomination in the summer but I was like
literally working out of a restaurant
there was like there's no way well
people that make $18,990 a year or less
so people that make $20,000 a year or
less make up right around 3040 percent
of Americans right so if 40% of
Americans maybe or less than 20,000 yeah
yeah it's like 60 million people make
less than $20,000 a year 200 million
Americans make less than $20,000 a year
that's 40% of this country 40% of
Americans made here less than 20,000
that's 40 percent of this country these
guys are coaching her they're scripting
everything she says you notice when she
goes off script because she suddenly
starts babbling and comprehensively this
is true then it goes on it shows that
video of her she goes off script and she
says I'm the boss I'm the boss you got a
run I'm catch me outside how about
you know and she obviously goes
off-script a lot of other similarities
too you see the founders of the Justice
Democrats talking years and years ago
about how we need to mobilize to fight
climate change as if it were World War
two
then she a OC speaking to Tonya he's
e-coat says exactly the same thing
almost verbatim now it's funny is she
keeps getting the lines somewhat wrong
so how many people are in the country
320 million something like that she says
in this country 200 million people make
less than twenty thousand that's forty
percent of the country so hold on 200
over 320 carry the 7 x no that's not 40%
it's much higher but she gets these
details wrong but she is repeating the
narrative and so then she'll say things
like it doesn't matter if you're
factually correct as long as you are
morally correct things like that
obviously she has a relationship she
admits it herself early on she says yeah
my brother submitted my nomination to
this group this political action
committee and I remember this from the
moment that she beat Joe Crowley when
she won that primary in New York this
story came out that she was working as
an obscure bartender and her brother
submitted her to a group to run for
Congress and the group liked her and
thought as she was a good choice this is
irrefutable this we know is the case the
question is is she an actress there's no
question that she's ignorant we know
that she's ignorant we know that she
reads talking points usually poorly and
when she goes off script she sounds even
less intelligent and educated than when
she's on script we know that she was
recruited by the Justice Democrats
that's just a fact we know that she
relies on the Justice Democrats for
content the content is virtually
identical between what they put out what
they put out since the 2016 race was
over and what they're still putting up
we know that she works closely with them
how do we know that she works closely
with them well her top aides include the
founders of the Justice Democrats
including one guy psychic Robert E that
there was that scandal that just came
out last week that AOC is funneling
money a million dollars into these shady
groups and Shady LL
which is ironic because of course the
far-left democrats just like AOC
including AOC are running on
transparency on getting soft money out
of politics meanwhile we find out she's
taking campaign contributions and paying
them to the tune of a million dollars to
consulting companies what are the
consulting companies do are they consult
it's just a way of taking that money and
just funneling it into other left-wing
causes and and hiding how the money is
being used so we know that this is true
she's got just as Democrats on her staff
would she be in in Congress without them
no she would still be slinging drinks in
Union Square there is no way that this
woman would be in Congress without them
she admits as much she wasn't gonna run
until they backed her and said we're
gonna put you in Congress so the
question is is she an actress or a
politician and the answer is what's the
difference I don't mean that in a glib
way it's kind of you know politics is
show business for ugly people is the old
line I mean this very sincerely what is
the difference between an actress and a
politician especially a member of
Congress she is an actress but it
doesn't make her much different from any
other member of Congress pop first of
all politics and acting are very similar
there is a negative side of this for bad
politicians and bad actors this means
that they lie all the time they're
narcissistic they just want to be the
center of attention all of those sorts
of things that's the negative version
for bad politicians and bad actors for
good politicians and good actors though
this means two things means one you are
concerned with the truth so for good
politicians they're concerned with truth
political truth cultural truth and
religious truth they are concerned with
pursuing the truth they're concerned
with pursuing the good they're concerned
with pursuing policies that will help
people policies that are both efficient
and that are moral and that are
politically justified right they are
concerned
political philosophy there they're not
ignorant they don't rely on people to
just give them all of their talking
points but they actually are interested
themselves I think of people like Edmund
Burke
Edmund Burke the great Irish statesman
was the founder of what would we would
call modern conservative thought and he
wasn't just sitting in a room writing
philosophy all day he was active he was
in politics he was an elected official
and he was one of the great philosophers
of his age really one of the great
political philosophers of any age he had
both of those things and a profound
concern for truth same thing with actors
the good actors real actors are not
faking it they're not pretending they're
not just reciting lines they are living
truthfully in imaginary circumstances so
they're taking imaginary circumstances
the circumstances of the set of the time
period of the character of all of these
things and they are living truthfully as
people in those circumstances would live
the other reason that politics and show
business are very similar is because
both politicians and actors when they're
really good have to love people that you
cannot be a misanthrope if you want to
be a good actor or a good politician if
you hate people you are gonna be so bad
at politics especially elected politics
all politics is is going to the Lions
Club in the VFW hall and the PTA showing
up and going to spaghetti dinners and
talking to people and meeting strangers
and hearing what they have to say and it
caring what they have to say if you
don't like meeting people you don't care
about what other people have to say you
don't like boots on the ground you know
marching through small towns and
campaigning and shaking hands and
pressing the flesh if you don't like
that you're gonna hate politics get
another job there are way easier ways to
make money the same thing with actors if
you hate people get a new job because if
you're an actor the thing you have to be
most concerned with most interested in
is people and not that you hate them or
you if you try to play a character if
you try to play a villain and you hate
that villain and you're going in and
you're just gonna do
the really bad guy you're gonna give a
bad performance you have to in some way
like the character that you're playing
you have to be on your characters side
you have to be interested in what makes
people tick you craft characters you
like the way that human nature works on
people and the way that circumstances
work on human nature those are what make
up a good politician and a good actor
now Alexandria Cassio Cortez is neither
of those she might be effective she
might be popular but she's not good in a
moral sense she's not doing the good in
politics she's not doing the good as a
performer still doesn't make her very
different than many congressmen and
we'll see there are new public opinion
polls out she might not be turning in a
great performance anyway before we get
to that first let's make a little money
honey with Lending Club if you are
carrying revolving debt that means
you're not paying off your card every
month and you could be paying thousands
of dollars in interest every year that
you don't have to with Lending Club you
can consolidate your debt and pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards
people are so stupid about this I don't
know if it's because they're lazier they
just don't know but they end up paying
you super high interest rates on credit
cards when if you just take two seconds
and get control of your finances it
could save you a ton of money go to
Lending Club calm / Knowles kena wles
tell them about yourself how much you
want to borrow pick the terms that are
right for you if you're approved your
loan is automatically deposited into
your bank account as little as a few
days
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over 35 billion dollars in loans
issued check your eight minutes borrow
up to 40 G's that is Lending Club comm
slash Knowles Lending Club comm slash
Knowles kena wles
all loans made by web bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender so we should also
be explicit about our Terms when I say
good and bad in this case in the case of
good actors and good politicians I'm
speaking in a moral sense the ones who
are doing good work the ones who are
putting on good performances the ones
who are doing good art and the ones who
are doing good politics
there's another sense of that which is
are they effective at it or are they
popular can they win an election plenty
of unartistic bad actors get big roles
and are very very famous plenty of badly
motivated ignorant uneducated
politicians have made it very very far
in our politics look no further than
Alexandria Cassio Cortes however the
performance aspect of all this is
basically Universal most congressmen are
glorified press secretaries that's
basically all they are congressmen have
very little power it's actually in in
terms of their day everything they do
all day which is raise money maybe go
out and vote possibly co-sponsor
legislation every so often probably the
most important thing they can do is go
on television which is why you see a lot
of congressmen go on TV all the time
it's because that is an opportunity to
get ideas out there either the ideas
that they have come up with or the ideas
that they're think tanks have come up
with were the idea is that their backers
or donors or whatever have come up with
and so in a purely performance-based
sense in in the sense of just how
effectively someone is getting their
name out there AOC is very good at that
I mean they're there that is why there's
so much crossover between show business
and politics obviously Ronald Reagan
obviously Donald Trump Sonny Bono
Jesse Ventura Arnold Schwarzenegger Fred
Thompson I mean the list goes on and on
and on of actors and performers turned
politicians so the question is how is
AOC doing at this and there is a huge
contingent now that is saying that a OC
is finished why because she's got killer
favorables very dramatically dropping
favorable ratings and increasing
unfavorable ratings so since September
her unfavorables are up 15 points her
favorables by the way are also up 7
points that's the part of this that
people are leaving out but overall the
the net effect of that is 7 - 15 per net
are down 8% now why or both favorables
and unfavorables increasing at the same
time it's because now everybody knows
about her her name recognition is also
way way up 21 points so as more and more
people hear about her some people start
to like her some people start to dislike
her more people are starting to dislike
her than to like her so who is she down
with who is her popularity dropping
among its dropping among adults
Republicans independence men women
whites and every age group it's mostly
dropping with older people
then with middle-aged people and then
the least of all with young people but
it's dropping across the board okay not
good news for AOC except her
favorability rating is increasing among
only two demographic groups it's
increasing among Democrats and it's
increasing among non-whites so is this
such a bad thing for AOC who was her
constituency her constituency is not 85
year old adult Republican men her
constituency isn't it really isn't any
of those people that her favorables are
down with her constituency is Democrats
and non-whites she has played too far
left liberal Democrat policies and as a
matter of cynical politics she is played
to racial identity this is what it's all
about for her that though that's her bet
that's what she's been betting on since
November really since before November
and it has worked
she's pandering to the far left of the
Democrat Party she's pandering on racial
politics to non-whites it's worked on
both counts frankly that seems like a
positive for AOC this proves the
political maxim proven true again and
again the only thing worse than being
talked about is not being talked about
the idea that there's no such thing as
bad press
AOC almost exclusively gets bad press
including from left-wing outlets why
because she doesn't know anything she's
blithely ignorant she's proudly ignorant
and she's always on TV she's always
getting
her face out there and the gamble that
you have to take is is it better to get
some negative attention or to get no
attention at all and we know this to be
the case getting your name out there is
a win if you're a member of Congress
this is why the congressmen are going on
TV all the time this is why they're
doing whatever they can to try to
attract attention there's 400 of them
there's over there's no way that they're
going to be able to get attention in a
in a media landscape such as ours unless
they go out there and put on a huge show
which is what she does so I think
overall I'm actually gonna break with
both the left and the right I mean
they're looking at numbers right now AOC
is currently less popular in her home
state of New York true blue New York
then Donald Trump is Donald Trump is
doing better in terms of approval
ratings than AOC is in New York okay
that's a bad headline for her first of
all Donald Trump is a New York figure
he's been in New York forever he is a
New York staple and so that plays into
it a little bit too but also maybe a OC
or a Oh sees handlers the people pulling
the marionette strings maybe they know a
thing or two maybe they know a thing or
two on how to ask a long-term incumbent
like Joe Crowley in a primary maybe they
know a thing or two on how to get a
congressman to be on television be the
center of political discourse constantly
maybe they know a thing or two about
which demographic groups they can afford
to lose in which they can stand to
benefit from if they lose those groups
it seems like the strategy is working
and even today very few people are
picking up on that but she seems to be
doing very well
I mean she's caught in this major
financial scandal now basically getting
no press there's still just I mean this
is what they accused Donald Trump of
doing they accused Donald Trump of
having some nefarious dealings
rushon collusion let's say no evidence
of Russian collusion of course but
that's what they accuse him of that's
what they want to talk about and then
Donald Trump sends that a tweet about
how much he doesn't like John McCain or
he sends that a tweet about how Kelly
and Conway's husband is a total loser
which he did today
and then everyone talks about that and
no one talks about
the scandal or the collusion or whatever
when they say Trump is distracting us a
OC is doing that for real
there is a scandal we know what the
scandal is she funneled a million bucks
to her cronies and her handlers during
her campaign nobody talks about it
because she says ridiculous things about
the environment and she puts out
proposals to abolish autumn automobiles
and she puts out proposals to knock down
every building in the country and she
says it's gonna cost 93 trillion dollars
and the way we're gonna pay for it is
abolish the entire energy industry and
print money from the Federal Reserve and
people say this is crazy this is crazy
they don't focus on the actual scandal
something tells me that the conspiracy
theory is true
AOC is an effective mouthpiece but look
political operators political thinkers
political activists have always needed
effective mouthpieces and very often
effective mouthpieces are not the
smartest people in the world so they've
got that but something tells me that her
handlers are pretty sharp that guy Chuck
Robb Barty is that his name what is his
actual name yes psychic Chakrabarti he's
a Harvard graduate not always a
recommendation of somebody not always a
testament to someone's intelligence
especially these days but he seems like
a sharp guy he was a big guy in the
Bernie Sanders campaign
he's a major person pulling the strings
here maybe they know what they're doing
and we'll have to see what the next step
is for them obviously they can't let the
favorables fall too much among everybody
else but right now it seems like they're
walking a tightrope and doing it pretty
well another candidate who's performing
a lot better than I think a lot of us
thought he would is baito O'Rourke 800
Rourke Robert Francis I'm Pedro Knowles
he's bata or work he roles at his
campaign a lot of people said the
campaign rollout didn't work he seems
like he's a privileged white guy he's
the kind of awkward ease moving his hand
up and down a lot he doesn't seem to
have much of a coherent message he's
trying to play both sides of the
Democrat Party the centrists and the far
left and then he wouldn't release his 24
our fundraising numbers and so the whole
news media even the left said see it's
all fake it's all astroturf he's not
gonna raise any money then a day later
total fake out he releases his
fundraising numbers he sets records 6.1
million dollars in 24 hours previously
we had been talking about how Bernie
Sanders broke all these records he was
raising what did he raise 5.9 million
Vado beat him he beat out Bernie means
Vado is a good campaign he's also rich
something very few people talk about
he's worth nine million dollars himself
his wife is the heiress to a multi
billion dollar fortune this guy is
loaded this guy has money coming out of
his ears and that always helps in
campaigns it always helps when you can
sell funds look at the current President
of the United States he's a better
campaigner than many of us expected now
why are people saying he had a bad
rollout well cuz he seems just like such
a creep he's such a weird creepy
feminist guy he's that weirdo that you
would never let your girlfriend near in
college he skateboards around water
burger parking lots he moves his hand up
and down like a parody of the 1940s he's
getting skewered on late night comedy
here's Jimmy Fallon sending up beta or
Roarke and now a message from Betty
O'Rourke
hi I'm better or ork and I'm excited
that's it I'm just excited oh yeah I'm
also running for president of the United
States I love the United States and I
love running in fact I worry this ran
eight miles to get here folks often say
to me we don't know much about you
better you know you ran against Ted Cruz
in Texas we know you're hot and then
usually the hot game comes up again but
who's the real better O'Rourke well I'm
sort of like if a compassionate head nod
turned into a person
because the truth is I care I care so
much where I eat salads I thank every
individual leaf for its sacrifice when I
donate blood I don't let them stop until
last possible second
god this country is great anyway
the question I get most is can you
actually beat Donald Trump and the
answer is heck yeah I was born to do
this I'm like if your friend's hot dad
had the energy of a Golden Retriever
thanks Evelyn god I feel so passionate
right now I love America I love
democracy I love air the whole sketch is
pretty good family goes on like this for
a while and then at the end of it and
she says something to the effect of and
hey are there people who have better
policy proposals than me yeah then it
kind of cuts out from there and so it is
a send-up I mean he's definitely making
fun of beta or Rorick however this is
another instance of no no press is bad
press and the only thing worse than
being talked about is not being talked
about because when you look at that send
up sure they are making fun of beta what
are they making fun of him for he's
really enthusiastic okay is that a bad
thing
he's got a lot of energy okay is that a
bad thing he's really positive is that a
bad thing
he donates blood is that a bad thing
he's a little airy
he's more enthusiastic than he is a
policy wonk okay when was the last time
we had a policy wonk president Bill
Clinton I guess was the last visiting is
that okay George W Bush wasn't a policy
wonk Barack Obama's not a policy wonk
Donald Trump's not a policy wonk who
cares so they they dig him a little bit
for not having really firm policies but
they're basically making him to like a
really nice happy excited enthusiastic
guy who wants to serve that's the best
possible way you could possibly be
mocked that's a win that's a win on a
roll out now I still have my doubts
about the bado campaign
because he is weird and creepy and he is
nothing he's trying to do Obama over
again and you can't do Obama over again
however the one thing we have to focus
on the one thing we can't forget he came
within three points of turning Texas
blue well he was running against Ted
Cruz who's a flawed candidate true he
was running against Ted Cruz who had a
very famous spat with Donald Trump and
Donald Trump didn't support him that
much sure Donald Trump would mop the
floor with made oh yeah I think that's
true still he came within three points
of turning Texas blue and the question
is not can baito turn Texas blue the
question is can bado
convince Democrats that there's a chance
that he can turn Texas blue duh totally
that's why they donated all that money
to him eighty million dollars in 2018
that's why he got so close in 2018 and
if he can convince Democrats that he
could possibly turn Texas blue then he
is saying to them I can possibly bring
in thirty eight electoral votes that
were guaranteed red I will end the
election in one state that promise
covers a multitude of sins that is a
real possibility and so all of bado
being really excited being like a golden
retriever okay it doesn't seem to hurt
him that much certain candidates are not
having a successful rollout we'll get to
that in a second but first today is your
day to get on the right side of history
which is in fact the title of Ben's new
book officially available as we speak
I've read it and I got to tell you
something you know my preference is on
books this book has words in it so you
know not like not as but nevertheless
this is a very good book this is an
important book the subject matter of
this book which is a a survey of Western
intellectual history has never been more
important you should get it go over to
Amazon Barnes & Noble or right side of
history book calm to get your copy I've
got a link on my Twitter page also you
can catch Ben on tomorrow's episode of
the conversation or he will be doing it
live book signing and answering all of
your burning questions so get the book
and tune in go to daily wire comm ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you got the Ben
Shapiro show you get the and reclaim
ensure you get them out well show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up on Thursday you get to ask
questions backstage we do those every
like five seconds now and you get
another Kingdom but most importantly you
get the leftist tears tumblr mmm
always delicious I believe this is made
up by the Justice Democrats who are
about to find themselves in a massive
campaign finance litigation but so make
sure you get yours before you drown go
to daily we're calm we'll be right back
with a lot more
so what is Beto's appeal why is he
having a better rollout than some people
thought he was he's appealing to the
lowest common denominator that's what
he's doing he is just pandering and
that's the way that politics is moving
especially on the left not exclusively
on the left but especially on the left
he is he was actually at a campaign stop
in Iowa and he said he just wants to be
a vessel for people's ideas he wants the
voters to mold him into the candidate
that they want can you imagine that he
basically goes up there and says hey
guys I stand for nothing I am nobody
I have no core beliefs all I've ever
done in my entire life is be in the
government I was on the El Paso City
Council then in Congress all I am is raw
ambition I was born to be in it man I
just want to be in it yeah just all I
care about is power and attention and
getting my ego stroked so just tell me
what to think and then I'll think it and
it's no big deal okay go that's the deal
it's pure pandering but that's what all
of the Democrat politicians are doing
right now other than Howard Schultz
Howard Schultz is the one guy going up
to Democrats and saying you're wrong
don't do this don't embrace socialism
and how is he being rewarded for that he
is not even a consideration in the 2020
race so far here is kirsten gillibrand
perfect mediocrity doing exactly the
same sort of pandering and the
difference here is that she's a terrible
politician Camille Polya says this she
is a perfect mediocrity of a candidate
and she is I mean she is nothing I was
thinking the other night I was talking
with some friends they said why is she
even running it's not because why not I
guess just to raise her name recognition
for next time or something or maybe run
for vice president because every
candidate is saying they have to pick a
female VP a beta or Roark said that
would be his preference they say all say
they sort of need a female vice
president okay maybe that's it here is
her pathetic pandering immigration is
not a security issue it is an economic
and a humanitarian and a family
there is no such thing as an illegal
human right well yeah there's no such
thing as an illegal human or they're
criminals though there is no such thing
as a criminal how about the guy in New
Zealand is he a criminal the guy who
shot up that mosque is that guy a
criminal we should ask Kirsten
Gillibrand this something tells me she
would say yes
she'd say okay so then there are people
who commit illegal acts and they're
criminals and they need to be punished
for their illegal acts we're at least
granting that as a category yeah yeah I
guess we we grant that okay so then for
instance people who invade a foreign
country who cross the border illegally
unvetted come in use welfare services
you commit crimes federal crimes at
higher rates who do all of those things
who break our laws some of our most
fundamental laws are they criminals well
okay so then they're illegal aliens
that's not a term of derision that's not
a slur that's not an insult that is the
most clinical term you can possibly use
you can what dreamer is that a more
precise term I have dreams all the time
undocumented worker I was an
undocumented worker when I was 14 at the
Subway sandwich store illegal immigrant
is they're not even really immigrants
immigrant sort of assumes that the
country is taking you in
we're not acquiescing to take them in
they're illegal aliens they're foreign
nationals here in this country illegally
and they're supposed to not be they're
supposed to be gone it's supposed to be
deported it's a precise term it's a
nobody no person is illegal beep beep
boop beep plug in new talking point
program no person is b.p people
obviously this is ridiculous pandering
and to say that it's not a national
security issue
let me ask Kirsten Gillibrand a question
how come every other country on Earth
considers immigration a national
security issue why do they have armed
guards along their borders why do they
have very robust systems for Customs and
Border Protection why do they build
walls why does every other country on
Earth do that except for us
is it that every other country on earth
is wrong and is viewing the issue in a
wrong way or are we viewing it are you
viewing it in the wrong way of course
it's a national security issue if you
can't determine who comes in and out of
your country what security do you have
why do we have guys with guns on the
border what does everyone else have guys
with guns on the border because it's a
security issue we know people are taking
in a ton of drugs every year we have a
major opioid crisis the average life
expectancy in the u.s. is decreasing two
years in a row that's not a security
issue of course it is so it's pure
pandering she doesn't do it as
effectively Beto's a lot better at this
she needs to learn to skateboard or
something but they're not the only ones
pandering now we have Elizabeth Warren
pledging to get rid of the electoral
college the electoral college this is a
big issue for Democrats now why because
Democrats want pure democracy they want
mob rule how do they want to push this
they push this by basically obliterating
civics education in this country so that
people mistakenly believe that the
United States is a democracy we are not
a democracy we've never been a democracy
the founding fathers feared democracy
tremendously that's why they set up the
electoral college the electoral college
is a very good institution now some
people ask they say look I don't
understand why we have the electoral
college let's just get rid of it right
that's the problem you are the last
person who should have any say over our
government if you say I don't know why
this exists let's get rid of it
this is Chesterton's fence only when you
can tell me the purpose of the electoral
college why it exists what it what it
has done throughout history why it has
persisted only then am I willing to even
have a conversation with you about
whether or not we should get rid of the
electoral college here's one example of
how great the electoral colleges this is
one any time someone brings up this
stupid idea to you answer them with this
the electoral college is responsible for
ending slavery without the electoral
college we would not have ended slavery
when we did
is that because in the 1860 presidential
election Abraham Lincoln did not win the
popular vote Abraham Lincoln not only
didn't get the popular vote he didn't
get 40% of the popular vote he got a
little less than 40% of the popular vote
but he won in the electoral college then
we had a civil war and then slavery was
abolished five years later that's pretty
good that's a good record now why why
does the electoral college function this
way why because the electoral college
functions as a safety measure for direct
democracy for mob rule why is pure
democracy supposed to be a good thing
because it prevents tyranny pure mob
rule is the worst tyranny I've ever
heard of at least when you talk about
actual tyrants actual dictators actual
bad monarchs at least there's a chance
those people were educated at least
there's a chance they have some higher
sense of if there's a chance they have
some practice at governing the mob what
is the mob the mob is given away to its
passions we say facts don't care about
your feelings mobs are pure feeling the
lynch mob is pure feeling and that's
what direct democracy very frequently
turns into is a lynch mob and that's
what they're calling for because they
want to be able to play on the passions
of voters they want to play on their
emotions it's why they always want
greater direct election direct election
of senators direct election of the
president Nancy Pelosi is calling for
this she wants to expand democracy so
much not just to get rid of the
electoral college she wants to lower the
voting age now to 16 I myself personally
I'm not speaking for my caucus I myself
have always been for lowering the voter
the voting age to 16 I think it's really
important to capture kids when they're
in high school when they're interested
in all of this when they're learning
about government to be able to vote that
is that is not enough to sit in other
words some of the priorities in this
bill or that transparency and openness
and excessive
and the rest that's a subject of debate
but my view is that I would welcome that
first of all she is speaking for her
caucus she said look it's just my view
I'm not speaking for all of course the
Democrats want to lower the age to 16
that's their can children is their
constituency if we lowered the voting
age to 16 Democrats would win many many
many more elections and listen to what
she says her language it's important
that we capture these woops did I say
that that's what she means I want to
capture them when they're still being
indoctrinated in public school while
they're still there being told only one
side of the story while they're still
uneducated they wants to grab them and
get the voting Democrat was once you
start voting a certain way you're more
likely to stick around that way the
question for Nancy Pelosi is why 16 why
stop there why not 15 15 year-olds are
in high school are 15 year olds really
stupider and less educated than sixteen
year olds know why not 14 14 year-olds
are in high school if this is about
rights if this is about the right to
vote if this is about representation
more representation this is about
capturing kids even why not lower it to
14 unless the vote is about something
else unless our electoral system is
about something else this is where we
put the cart before the horse this is
where the tail wags the dog
there is nothing intrinsically wonderful
about voting there's nothing about the
act of voting that is so intrinsically
good and virtuous and moral and terrific
voting suffrage our electoral system is
a mechanism for good governance and that
has a lot of moral qualities to it but
voting itself who cares the purpose of
voting is to have a good government the
purpose of our government is not to make
more people vote and Democrats seem to
be saying that these days say oh we need
to extend suffrage to everybody to two
year-olds the ones that we didn't kill
we're gonna make them vote and they're
all going to vote for Democrats why
maybe the purpose of voting is a little
different maybe there are moral hazards
to having 15 year-olds vote or 12 year
olds vote maybe that's not a great idea
and and this is ultimately a sort of
selfishness I mean this is what a
self-obsessed age gets to which is it's
all about me me me it's all about me
voting I want to get the little sticker
that says I voted and yeah and a vote
vote or die and I'm it's me me me look
how great I am I'm gonna take a picture
no it's not about you if I were told
today that we could have a much better
government if I didn't vote I would not
vote I would never vote again now if I
were told we would get a worse
government if I don't then I'll vote
okay and then I want to vote but I don't
actually care about the act itself for
me let's not forget with this specific
example the kids are idiots here is a
prime example from Down Under
when when people are getting attacked in
their own first of all totally
Australian move ta em where the kid if
you couldn't see it this teenage kid
goes up to an Australian senator with it
with his camera out and an egg in his
hand and smacks the egg on the Senators
face and the senator turns around it's
being reported that he punched the kid
in the face which he actually didn't he
slapped the kid on the face as the kid
deserves if that kid's parents had
slapped him in the face he wouldn't
behave like that and then the kid gets
tackled to the ground which of course he
should this is a senator this is a major
politician some kid goes up and
physically assaults him yeah that kid's
gonna have some trouble and by the way
for people defending the kid because the
senator made controversial comments for
those defending the kid the kid didn't
just go up there were a lot of news
cameras the kid didn't just go up and
take an egg and throw it at him
before the kid picked up the egg he
picked up his cell phone what the kid
was trying to do was get instafamous so
he goes up he takes the cell phone he's
gonna have a really good insta post and
then he hits the senator on with the egg
now in America because we're sort of
more
put together polite people here the
version of this that we just saw was
Dianne Feinstein telling off those kids
who were trying to tell her how to do
her job the Australian version obviously
she smacked somebody in the face because
Australia was founded as a penal colony
and they're you know they're a little
more aggressive down there this is you
see this with Russell Crowe you see this
with the Mel Gibson you see a lot of
Australian people very famously the
actual takeaway from this is not did the
bodyguards react too strongly to the kid
maybe they did maybe they didn't I don't
know the reaction is well the senator
made offensive remarks about the
shooting in New Zealand yeah I guess
sure the the actual takeaway from this
act itself is that kids are kids kids do
stupid things
kids are not mature this is a truism
they're not they're immature they're
juvenile they're kids we don't want our
country run by little kids we basically
already have it they're just overgrown
little kids we don't need to make that
problem worse but the the issue of
pandering is going to get worse this is
the natural temptation of democracy this
is what happens as democracy expands as
you get more and more pandering more and
more pandering to the lowest common
denominator and that accelerates on
itself because the more pandering you
get the broader you make democracy so
you start abolishing good institutions
the electoral college you start saying
we need to lower the voting age to 16
pretty soon it'll be lower the voting
age to 14 that is a really difficult
aspect of democracy the way to fight
that is to reinstate civics education to
say it proclaim it from the rooftops we
are not a democracy we are a democratic
republic we have a constitution we have
traditional institutions that are
safeguards against this sort of mob rule
all simple government is bad all
shallows are clear we need to really
really shout that from the rooftops
because they've got the megaphone
they've got the bullhorn they are trying
to promote this not just through 2020
not just through one election but
through so many future elections and the
the combination with the associate
between this issue and the education
scandal that we were talking about last
week is very clear when we lose the
liberal arts when we lose education we
lose our capacity for freedom watching a
play out in real time got a lot more to
get to we'll do it tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
Audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19